at least 60 people are reported dead in
wildfires raging outside of the capital
of Greece a pair of large fires is
burning in coastal areas near Athens
some tourists and residents were forced
to flee to the beach for safety rescue
crews from across Europe are racing to
Greece to help gale force winds and dry
conditions are fueling these flames this
is the deadliest fire season to hit
Greece in more than a decade Seth Doane
has the latest
good morning Greece's issued an urgent
appeal for help in battling the worst
fires they've seen there since 2007 a
wildfire tore through a beach resort
community popular with tourists and
retirees the Coast Guard and passing
boats reported picking up around 700
people who had fled to beaches for
safety but tragically the fire swept
through too quickly for others to save
themselves and in some cases families
reportedly trapped behind a wall of fire
and smoke rescue crews reported finding
more than 20 people huddled together on
a beach and the Red Cross told local
media that some had apparently been
family members who were found hugging
each other the fire was ignited on
Monday but winds died down a bit today
offering some relief but the fire is not
yet under control for CBS this morning
Seth Doane Rob